jp morgan has been fined 200 million
dollars pretty absurd what this is for
they refined 125 million by the sec they
were fined 75 million dollars by the
cftc so what exactly is it for these
regulators are claiming that there was
widespread failures to preserve staff
communications on personal mobile
devices messaging apps and emails more
than 100 employees exchanged tens of
thousands of messages via whatsapp text
messages and personal email accounts
about business dealings from january
2018 until november of 2020. the lapses
were institution-wide and known to
senior management now of course we have
a quote this comes from sanjay wadwa is
the deputy director of enforcement at
the sec says jp morgan's actions
hindered several commission
investigations and required the staff to
take additional steps that should not
have been necessary now of course when
you go ahead and you look what was j.p
morgan's response here well it's pretty
simple the jp morgan securities uh team
or division they admitted that to the
changes and to violating the securities
law they agreed to retain a compliance
consultant and conduct a comprehensive
review of its policies and procedures
related to the retention of electronic
communications found on personal devices
they've also agreed to implement
improvements to compliance policies in
addition to the fine and then we also
know that earlier this year jpmorgan had
its bankers installing their work phones
a messaging and calling app called movis
which records all of the calls so trying
to actually go ahead and document all of
the electronic communication we have a
quote from gary ginsler it says as
technology changes it's even more
important that registrants ensure that
their communications are appropriately
recorded and are not conducted outside
of official channels in order to avoid
market oversight now this is super super
interesting to me because one everyone's
going to run wild they're going oh my
god they're fine 200 million one 200
million really isn't that big of a fine
for a large bank like this right yes it
is a bit it is a big number 200 million
but i don't think it's a big fine the
second thing is i actually think this is
probably one of the hardest things for
financial institutions to do you have
tens of thousands of employees and if a
hundred one hundred out of tens of
thousands of employees ends up using
personal uh text messages whatsapp email
etc that can be a big problem there's a
lot of people when they see this back
damn you know what i one time used my
personal email for something or i one
time sent a text message one time i
called i didn't record the call right it
happens i think here what is really
interesting is the regulators are saying
well we were doing an investigation into
something and because these
communications were not in the official
channels they weren't documented as they
normally are we were still able to
access the information it just made us
our job harder made us to go access it
somewhere else and so ultimately what i
think is that people are going to dunk
on this they're going to go crazy my
guess is this happens at every single
institution it also happens in the
technology sector as well so this is
probably one of the hardest things and
doesn't excuse the behavior right it's
wrong they broke the rules they should
get punished that's how it works every
single bank probably has the same exact
issue and so do many other companies one
of the things that's gonna be really
interesting is as a venture capital
funds want to invest in crypto they are
all going or many of them are
registering as registered investment
advisors ria one of the things people
don't understand is in a venture capital
fund historically you have a 20 what's
called a non-qualified investment
threshold nqi that non-qualified
investment threshold basically means
you're making investments that aren't
into the pure equity of a business in
order to continue to have the venture
capital uh kind of label and to get
certain exemptions and benefits of being
a venture capital fund you can't invest
more than 20 of your fund in what is
considered those nqi investments now
crypto and tokens and all that type of
stuff falls in the nqi bucket so if you
have a fund and you want to go invest in
crypto if you want to put 20 or less of
your fund into the crypto assets then
you can go ahead and be a venture
capital fund
if you want to do more than 20
of the fund in it you cannot use the
venture capital structure the label and
the benefits instead you have to
register as a registered investment
advisor and then you can go and put 100
of your fund into these types of assets
when you go ahead and you register as an
ria there are certain regulations that
you have to follow certain rules things
like documenting all of the electronic
communication is one of those things so
you can see it's a big decision people
have to go through training they have to
get registered they have to go ahead and
they have to get their all of their
employees to meet certain testing
requirements they also have to install a
ton of infrastructure and so as we move
from the legacy financial world into
this new world the tech industry has
technically been operating as
technologists as corporations they
haven't really fallen under the ideas of
some of this type of regulation so while
it's easy to point and say oh the legacy
folks they're breaking the rules my
guess is that there's a big learning
curve ahead for a lot of technology
organizations venture capital funds etc
so 200 million big number but i don't
know if this is as big of a deal as
people want to make it what do you guys
think they're calling each other hitting
each other i'm trying to make some money
that's what i think they were doing 100
people that's all it takes that's all
you need trying to call people tell them
what trades are happening so you what's
up do you think it's a big deal or you
don't think it's a big deal uh
i think it's a big deal yes i don't
think the money is a big deal
yeah so you're basically like hey they
should be following the rules but the
fine isn't a huge number yeah of course
i mean 200 million sounds like a [ __ ]
ton of money right but it's really not
when you think of the size of their
business they've had fines that are
bigger than this in the past for sure so
i think that it's a big idea that they
should uh that they they shouldn't be
doing this right and and to be fair
there is difficulty in tracking some of
this stuff i know we mentioned that they
created this app that basically you uh
if you make a call you have to register
it and it gets recorded in all these
things to be determined i think if
people are going to follow those rules
it's almost impossible to track to some
degree right whether you give someone a
phone or you use their phone or whatever
communication right literally you can
meet someone in person and talk to them
without it being recorded so i think
it's always going to be hard or
difficult to track but ultimately i
think these are the things that are
difficult to do because these are the
criticisms that wall street gets and
these banks get is that people are doing
shady stuff behind the scenes uh they're
doing things that are illegal that
shouldn't be allowed and these things
whether you can prove that someone made
money off of it or they didn't or gained
some kind of advantage from a market
perspective it doesn't really matter in
my opinion right they're not following
the rules that are set up by the sec so
if these rules are theirs that they
should be enforced uh hopefully some of
the technology changes that jp morgan
has made will be helpful but on on kind
of a headline number 200 might grab some
people's attention 200 million but
ultimately it's not really that much
money for the bank